in the recent GOP debate there was a
moment where Nikki Haley Vivek went
after each other was heated the entire
place was on fire I was in the audience
I was watching Haley was defending
Ukraine saying how dare we support a
Putin he's a thug he's a killer didn't
he just kill his opponent for Goshen and
we're watching this thing taking place
and if we're sitting here stay out of
the way let Russia take over Ukraine
what are we doing we should defend our
allies NATO since we're putting money
into NATO we should defend NATO so that
prompted me to say let's investigate
this Brandon brought this up and I said
how big is NATO how much money are we
spending in NATO who's scarier NATO or
bricks Are we more worried about members
in NATO or members and Bricks which is
Brazil Russia India China South Africa
which party you can throw Iran there as
well what is the pro and kind of NATO
why is it still around the whole thing
was prompted by Russia but Russia fell
in 91 do we still continue putting money
into it did anybody ever leave NATO did
anybody come back to later who is not
the adjoin NATO a bunch of different
questions that we're going to get into
today if you give Ali out of this video
give it Thumbs Up And subscribe to the
channel let's get right into NATO what
does NATO stand for the North Atlantic
Treaty Organization and an
intergovernmental military alliance
between 31 member states that was
established in 1949 after World War II
because everybody feared Soviet Union so
NATO is a collective security system
it's independent member States agree to
defend each other against attacks during
the Cold War NATO operated as a check on
the threat posed by the Soviet Union so
it's kind of like being part of a gang
and everybody teams up with each other
if somebody messes with you you messed
up with me so if you want to know who's
part of NATO as well as who joined first
here's a listen 1949 to 12 countries
that joined Belgium Canada Denmark
France Iceland Italy Luxembourg
Netherlands Norway Portugal the United
Kingdom and United States 1952 is Greece
and Turkey and 59 it's Germany in 66
France is the first one that leaves
they're like listen we're out of here we
don't want to deal with you guys NATO
they were offended they were upset
they're out later on in 2009 they
rejoined 1982 at Spain in 1999 it's
Czech Republic formerly Czechoslovakia
then it's Hungary Poland then in 2004
it's Bulgaria Soviet Latvia Lithuania
Romania Slovakia and Slovenia formerly
Yugoslavia and then in 2009 it's Albania
Croatia in 17 is Montenegro and 2020 is
North Macedonia and in 2023 Finland
making it 31 members so it's important
when you see that somebody may say so
what all these people are joining that's
that's totally fine I want you to look
at this map on statista and look at the
years from dark blue if you look at the
dark navy blue to lighter blue to
lighter lighter lighter and all of a
sudden it's green and yellow notice how
it starts all the navy blue is far left
far from Russia meaning Russia doesn't
care with those countries at that time
but notice it gets lighter which is
getting close to Russia and lighter and
then the yellow and the light blue and
the more yellow now they're getting
right next to Russia and Russia is now
sitting there saying NATO what plans do
you have here what are you trying to do
it's almost as if you're pushing me to
have to to do something and take action
against Ukraine Poland and some of these
other countries you ever wonder why
Jamie Diamond CEO of Chase has a 900
million art collection or Steve Cohen
1.1 billion art collection or Microsoft
has nearly a billion dollar collection
the company 5 000 art pieces in 180
different locations worldwide why
because billionaires and millionaires
understand one of the ways to hedge
against inflation money being printed
market crash interest rates is to buy
non-duplicatable assets and one of them
is Art Fine Arts and that's why today's
sponsor is Masterworks let me tell you a
little bit about Masterworks you may be
watching the same pad I'm not a
millionaire or a billionaire I can't
afford to buy Warhol or Banksy or
Basquiat how am I going to buy that well
Masterworks allows you to buy fractional
shares like buying a share of Apple you
buy a share of a Banksy painting or a
Warhol piece you're able to do that
through Masterworks this is why over 800
000 people have signed up with
Masterworks offerings have sold out
within minutes and many of you have
already created accounts and some of you
that haven't this is your chance to skip
the waiting list and start your
collection today just click on the link
in the description go to masterworks.art
forward slash value team and once again
masterworks.org forward slash Valentine
or click on a link below this is when
Russia all of a sudden woke up because
what's interesting while we're looking
at this just this year July 11th of 2023
leaders agree to expedite Ukraine's NATO
membership now you got to realize these
countries Russia is looking at these
guys were former Russia he's looking at
saying why are you doing this to me
what's your motive here again this is
really piss and put enough now you may
watch us and say who cares Pat do we
want to make him happy do we want to
make our enemy happy this is not a guy
we like he just killed his opponent who
is our priority to make the guy happy
some may say priority maybe not to start
a world war three that's why we started
this right so imagine you were putting
your like wait a minute you're getting
all the stuff that's getting stronger
how many ballistic missiles do you have
that can be targeted in my country I got
to take care of my country right look
what this chart shows NATO defense
system if you go all the way to the
bottom right you'll see the ballistic
missiles you'll notice Germany Romania
Poland Spain and turkey us has missiles
in those countries including NATO and
Germany that can directly Target Russia
and this is what upsets Putin so why
July 11 2023 they're trying to expedite
the process of getting Ukraine to
membership right according to this
article number five if Ukraine is part
of NATO and Russia attacks them not only
can they but they have to respond
because it's in the treaty to defend
NATO the parties agree that an armed
attack against one or more of them in
Europe or North America shall be
considered an attack against them all
okay all and it continues at the end to
say
such action as it deems necessary
including the use of Armed Force to
restore and maintain the security of the
North Atlantic area this is in their
articles you attack one or more we can
attack you and Russia essentially if
they speed up the process of Ukraine and
Russia attacks Ukraine that means NATO
can now attack Russia because it's part
of the treaty so before we tell you who
spends the most money for you know the
budget for NATO let's look at pros and
cons because maybe there's a lot of Pros
for NATO for us to have that and then
you can look at the cons as well Pros
deterrence NATO's main goal is to deter
aggression against its member states by
having a strong military Alliance NATO
makes it clear to potential adversaries
that any attack on a NATO member would
be met with a strong response defense
NATO committed to defending its member
states if they are attacked this has
been demonstrated in practice most
notably during the 1999 bombing of
Yugoslavia when NATO intervened to stop
the Serbian government's ethnic
cleansing campaign in Kosovo stability
NATO has helped to promote stability in
Europe since its founding in 1949 by
providing a forum for cooperation and
consultation NATO has helped to prevent
conflict between its member states
values NATO is based on the shared
values of democracy individual liberty
and the rule of law these values are
important to many people in Europe and
North America and NATO helps to uphold
them now let's take a look at the cons
cost NATO is a costly Alliance the
United States spends a significant
amount of money on NATO which some argue
is not necessary next unnecessary some
argue that NATO is no longer necessary
in the post-cold War era they point out
that there's no longer a clear threat
from the Soviet Union or any other major
power aggressive some argue that NATO is
an aggressive Alliance that is more
interested in expanding its influence
than its deterring aggression they point
to NATO's interventions in Yugoslavia
and Libya as evidence of this
ineffective some argue that NATO has
been ineffective in preventing conflict
in Europe they point to Wars and Bosnia
Herzegovina Kosovo and Ukraine as
evidence of this now in 2016 Trump
pointed out something that really got a
lot of people upset but it got a lot of
American people saying why are we doing
this it doesn't make any sense they pull
out the data of what percentage of NATO
we put into so if you look at 2022 you
would notice United States all the way
at the top we put in not only the most
money but percentage-wise we put the
second and highest percentage of our GDP
at 3.47 percent then look at the drop
off how quickly the total dollar goes to
UK and then you have Germany France
Italy Canada Poland Netherlands and by
the way if you look at all these
countries most of them are close to
Russia but we are not close to Russia
but why are we putting three and a half
percent into this well the rules only
two percent you don't have to put more
than two percent we're going three point
four seven percent some may say we're
doing this that allows us to have
control we have the loudest mic when we
say what to do we're putting in the most
money how much of the money we're really
putting into let me kind of break down
what three point four seven percent is
so if you notice U.S 811 billion then
you have UK at 7 30 which means we're 11
times more than what UK puts in then
it's Germany 63 billion France 57 Italy
33 Canada 27 Poland 15 billion
Netherlands 15 billion Spain 15 billion
so you know when you listen to the
arguments the Santos Vivek or Nikki
Haley and you know Romney and who should
I listen to I don't know who I should
listen to one side says why are we
spending so much money why why is this
establishment so obsessed with military
industrial complex spend spend spend
spend make money for Raytheon Boeing
General Dynamics north of Grumman you're
making all money for these guys that
eventually give to your party that's
what the argument is made from one side
the other side is sitting there saying
wait a minute who do you worry about
more bricks or NATO who's part of NATO
you're worried about Germany you're
worried about France you're worried
about UK let me kind of break down to
you as part of bricks are you worried
about Brazil not really are you worried
about India no we have a decent
relationship with them are you worried
about China yeah we are worried about
China are you worried about Russia we
are worried about Russia are you worried
about South Africa who South Africa now
I'm not really worried about him how
about Iran well Iran is kind of part of
them because China invest into how about
Saudi Arabia well they work with
everybody they're kind of in the middle
but they're not taking oil would want so
they're probably tied to China a little
bit but I am worried about China I am
worried about Russia so what does brics
look like compared to Nato here's what
it looks like formation your NATO 49
bricks 2009 type of organization
military security brics economic
political and cultural cooperation NATO
31 countries brics five total population
NATO 954 million that's 13 of the world
population lucky bricks 3.21
45 percent of the world population with
only five countries compared to 31 GDP
45 of world GDP brics 31 and a half
percent so smaller big economies U.S
Germany France UK Poland brics China
India Brazil who do you not want to piss
off uh do you not want to piss off
bricks so you may say well Pat I mean
I'm not understanding where you're going
with this are you saying we are we are
for strengthened in Ukraine Are We Now
what direction are we going with this
here's all I'm saying to you one can be
paranoid about the fact that NATO wants
us to send all the money because we have
a big economy don't worry about it you
guys can afford it you're rich you're
like the rich family and all your
cousins when you go out they want you to
pay for everything they're annoying what
do you think about people like that that
want you to pay for everything because
you're rich that's how they look at
America but one may say listen
China Russia those guys see themselves
as an equal to you you don't want to
kind of forget about those guys that's a
real threat that's not necessarily a
best friend of ours right for us to sit
there and be like yeah totally fine I
think we should stay paranoid with
everybody and kind of watch our money
because we're kind of going into a lot
of debt right now Fair argument but the
idea is to watch for everyone's way that
they're hurting the country that matters
to you and I the most if you live in
America that's what matters to me the
most and that's what ought to matter to
you also the most so let's answer a few
different questions here number one is
NATO preventing world war three from
happening some can make a strong
argument that NATO's encroachment on
Russia is a leading cause of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine those in favor of
NATO might argue that the NATO policy is
an attack against one is an attack
against all is an effective determinant
to Russia's aggression against around
the country somebody say you know what
Russia is not going to want to attack
one of these guys because we all have to
attack Russia I said like you know we're
just not going to doing it we're going
to leave it alone maybe it's working
maybe it's not but both arguments have a
good point the other question what would
World War III look like if nuclear
missiles were launched 70 percent of the
world would be killed pretty much
instantly so in a non-nuclear U.S is not
really a threat for many different
reasons one of the reasons is we've got
two big oceans between us and Russia and
China let's take a look at this here
together ranking U.S according to
globalfirepower.com it puts U.S ranking
number one and then Russia number two in
China three if you look at U.S versus
Russia here's a comparison you'll see
how they have a broken down Manpower
they give to Russia air power us land
power Naval power natural resources
financials it's Russia Logistics
geography goes to us but this doesn't
tell the whole story I'll give you here
in a minute some other numbers you would
you know destroyers and aircraft
carriers and Hello Carriers we'll go
into that here in a minute let's look at
U.S versus China China being ranked
number three Manpower obviously China
Air power us land power Naval China
natural resources us financials them
Logistics geography us but if you look
at the top countries with destroyers
okay you would see us at number one with
92 China at 50 Japan 36 Russia's at 15.
even if you combine China and Russia
together they're at 65 we're at 92 after
Russia at South Korea India France UK
Mexico and if we look at aircraft
carriers total in the world there's an
estimated 46 of the 46 20 hour hours
France has got four Japan's got four
China's got only three Italy two UK 2
Australia to Egypt to South Korea to
then India one Russia one Brazil won
Spain won Thailand one meaning of the 46
U.S almost has half of the entire fleet
so in a non-nuclear war U.S has fined in
a nuclear war 70 percent of the world is
gone we don't have to worry about that
part but if we can't figure out a way to
prevent a nuclear war from happening
it's probably a good idea don't you
think so in closing final thoughts here
so between NATO bricks all this stuff
we're talking about Pat you know what do
you think about these these things here
well first of all NATO like who in NATO
hates us think about NATO like most of
it is Europe right who in NATO hates us
they may look at us and say ah you know
these guys are such capitalists all they
care about is money you guys are not
living your life you are selfish people
Americans they don't hate us they don't
like us right if you think about it like
when you go to Europe some restaurants
when you see it from America oh you're
American you work very hard you have no
life you chase the money we have family
we have tradition we have fashion like
they look at us in a different way now
when you think about bricks
China Russia if you add Iran as part of
China's deal I know the eye stands for
India not Iran
um they don't like us
some may even say they hate us I lived
in Iran 10 years they do not like
America they hate America so imagine you
got a billionaire who's your enemy
but he doesn't really care for you much
okay but you have somebody that works a
regular job but they hate you
they're envious of you who has more
power this one's got more resources than
this one but what is this one at this
one's a True Believer that's patient
and it's going to be patiently waiting
till they get their opportunity to seek
vengeance against those State Envy and
those they hate
they feel that way towards us
of course we have to make sure to tame
them and keep them calm and at least
some kind of a relationship there and
figure out a way to do business together
but they're not sitting around saying oh
you know let America get as big as they
want no no no
FDR said something once years ago
Roosevelt he said the following
he said in politics nothing happens by
accident
if it happens you can bet it was planned
that way nothing happens by accident so
covet wasn't an accident the whole world
shut down for about a year year and a
half two years
so that was intentional FDR said that
isn't that the Democrats favorite
President of all time it's kind of a
weird thing to say right
so maybe some of these things are
planned so China Russia may not have
access to the Destroyers or the ships or
the aircraft carriers that we have
but they are training on bio Warfare and
cyber warfare that's not on a Leader's
bulletin how do we measure that we don't
have a way of measuring that so my whole
purpose of saying this to you is I think
it's best we as American stay paranoid
with anybody whose number one priority
in their lives is not America
and we keep America's number one
priority over Ukraine over relationship
with Russia or China or any of that
let's lead with America first and then
comes everybody else instead of trying
to solve everyone's problems and create
unnecessary enemies especially waking
some of them up that we're cornering
them to make a point or else we're
publicly humiliating them it's that kind
of situations that could lead to a
nuclear war nobody wants that we'd like
to figure out a way to avoid that if you
got value out of this video give it a
thumbs up subscribe to the channel if
you've not seen a video we're made on
military industrial complex click you to
watch it take everybody bye-bye
foreign
[Music]